we're here with funny man writer actor
and overall just lovely human being Adam
Devine
oh you're back welcome back okay my face
hurt I have a question for you guys how
was it shooting together
you didn't episode of workaholics where
he played your dad that became your
brother I've been wanting to play his
father for literally years you guys are
related and you know all three of us
have in common what that we're super old
we are old yeah so I thought we'd play a
grace Helbig show classic game called
where old
I felt that in my bones either of you
break your necks no no I can't do it I
leave a get right to the envelope okay
here's how the game works I'm gonna list
four items in a category and you have to
place them into their appropriate decade
we have the 80s then 90s the ox ox which
is which is like the 2000s okay and then
we have the 2010 so 80's 90's thoughts
and tens but the way buzz in is by
creating a buzzer sound that is
something an old person would say mine
uh mine is uh oh he died cuz that they
always have friends yeah that's okay and
they're always shocked oh I'm gonna go
with fiber perfect something you think
about a lot way to get when you get
older it yeah it helps things move the
long that is true okay it's a pooping
thing okay I got it okay you can do this
I have faith in you guys social media
okay
put these in a decade LinkedIn six
degrees
Yik yak and game line he died
Adam Yik yak the arts six degrees calm
that's on some new new 2010 LinkedIn
yeah freaking like my grandma site right
game line.com 1978 but at will count
that is the eighty LIBOR Jack Yik yak is
is olds the hills that's the 80s six
degrees calm that is the what LinkedIn
tens game line tens hit us with it
you're both incorrect game line game
line is the 80s thank you okay six
degrees is the 90s LinkedIn is the auth
and Yik yak is the tens because there
was no internet in the eighties right no
I made that mistake I got it no now
wrong you learn age so learn my son okay
max our TV shows ready
if you can put these in a decade we have
home improvements 8 simple rules full
house and bluebloods
ok cyber bluebloods
what I just like to say what home
improvement that's old as the hills
that's it that's actually for sure 80s 8
simple rules never heard of it I'm gonna
go with me twice
full house old as the hills 1980s I got
two of those right I'm pretty sure Blue
Bloods not a real show 2010 home
improvement very very real show and that
is 90s you said 80 that is 19 1992 8
simple rules 80s sure yes
full house I believe you were right with
the eighties so I will say Adam got more
correct than Jack oh yeah whole house is
80s home to mid 90s shapes and images be
Ott's
and blue bloods is the tens okay last
one ready alright uh dance moves the
Cabbage Patch the ketchup song wobble
and dud dip it's a photo finish the
wobble doo-doo-doo bubble it's a new one
and that is a that is a 2010 er the
Cabbage Patch that that classic 80s did
it
- the ketchup song dance not real very
fake that is an off how would that dance
be though if it were real I think it
would be I imagine you have the packet
and you're going but then if you're me
you suck it dry at the end you got to
get a new chair for Dwayne the rock
Johnson he's - Joe we're trying to set
it up so that it truly makes it you know
what Adam you got all of them correct